Hachi Machi middle class famous tour
update can't be uh-oh we got a couple
alerts going out straighten them out a
little bit Yeah guys so uh we're coming
to Seattle and Portland unfortunately
Seattle is sold out so if you want
tickets you're gonna have to come see us
in Portland then we're going to Kansas
City Springfield St Louis Nashville in
the Philadelphia that show sold out
already three months ahead of time we
added a second Show tickets are on sale
right now then we're going up to
Providence Rhode Island that's going to
sell out in Boston there's low ticket
alert so get those tickets now we'd love
to see you do it welcome so another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah a little
shall we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out they go to be
classy yeah or to just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host stage Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at Aunt Cody's basement she's
very excited okay just got her stimulus
check okay it was held up in the mail
for a long time you can't tell her
nothing she said can't get a castle up
there good to know my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me slightly
amused this week I kind of hit him a
little bit maybe a B plus on that 30. no
either way he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he's an international businessman he's
not to be tripled in the boardroom or
the bedroom he's the prince of Park
Avenue but always King of the boardwalk
baby like a piece of funnel cake give it
up for KJ it's Kevin James Ryan Hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate if you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are good good
and then obviously uh my favorite
website of all time I don't want to see
for the rest of the group my favorite
website of all time
www.patreon.com all your garbage check
it the [ __ ] out it's a party over there
that's what a turkey is baby and having
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good you love them we love them
give it up for T-Bone McMuffin Toby
McMullen everybody what's up dudes
T-Bone good to see you pal oh it's a
beautiful day finally not sweating our
balls off in here yeah nice and cool got
a good vibe going because gang we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time she's a new pal of ours she's a
very funny stand-up comedian she tours
all over and she has an amazing special
out right now that you gotta check out
called from ho to housewife do me a
favor give it up for Brittany Schmidt
everybody there she is with a Diet Coke
yeah coming with lipstick all over the
river
that's great I saw it it looks like it's
out of a Playboy magazine
it's like a grade school teacher you can
take the girl out of the Midwest but
you're gonna have to pry the diet coke
out of my cold
here we get the lipstick on your teeth
oh yeah you know that's a tough look
that's when you find out you don't have
friends when you have it on your teeth
and then you just have been you know
chatting it up all night and nobody
[ __ ] tells me unless I hate you no
matter who you are I'm gonna say yo you
got a booger yo you have lipstick on
your teeth Yo your breath is rocking
yeah because I want people to do that to
me I don't know if my breasts kicking or
not so when you get home and you look in
the mirror after like a like a night out
and you're like ah [ __ ] yeah I had
spinach three days ago how the [ __ ] is
it still in there
in your nose and then you never go to
dinner with those people again no never
never we're not friends all right give
us a scoop here a Midwest gal Midwest
cow where'd you grow up Mom Dad give us
the whole scoop what's the origin story
here I'm from Wisconsin small town
called Big Bend Wisconsin okay 1200
people holy [ __ ] um yeah we grew up from
the 1800s Jesus Christ yeah 1200 people
in the whole town yeah
my God yeah we grew up on a 36 Acre Farm
horses only you say that but then let me
tell you who was around us we had people
cooking meth next door nice people
beating their kids right next door to
that okay and then across the street
this is the most [ __ ] up one
can I get [ __ ] up and dark right away
yeah what do you mean I mean I'm worried
I don't know what's going to top finesse
and child abuse but yeah let's [ __ ]
do it
um they'll get a couple of Democrats
a couple of liberal [ __ ]
uh the woman the mom tried to kill
herself and wasn't successful and the
dad walked in and saw that she was
trying to do that and shot her oh and
the police called it suicide holy [ __ ]
now you're down to 1198 people what the
[ __ ] hey whatever your wife wants you
know what I mean so it sounds nice on
paper but we were surrounded by chaos
all right yeah I'll give you that yeah
what when you say horse farm what does
that actually entail what were you doing
with the horse 12 horses my mom just
liked to ride horses and make us clean
up their [ __ ] did you sell them no
that's just an expense that's a line
yeah yeah yeah have the family make
money what'd your mom and dad do for a
living my dad was an electrician and
then my mom was a real estate broker did
they do well 36 Acres yeah they did
twice it was six dollars no um it's like
it's a penthouse on Park Avenue here's
the thing they did well together and
then when they decided to get divorced
which was when I was about five their
divorce lasted nine years Jesus so by
the end of it they were drained yeah my
mom got everything and then my dad got
like was living in a spec house that
they built together wow so they built a
house so I was always real Rich a spec
house I never heard about it on like The
Sopranos which I don't understand what
that is what is the spec house it's a
house that you build to sell okay yeah
all right so that was the plan and they
they bought the farm together and then
my mom got did it have a name like the
Schmidt Estates or anything no name
that's what you got to do well my mom
was planning to do with this other piece
of land she had in Muskego down the
street she was going to make a
subdivision and she was going to name it
after my sister just to prove how much
she hated me yeah
let's be called Heather Maria States but
then welcome to not brittanyville
yeah but Brittany Lane my other daughter
Park yeah wait a minute hold on now
listen I know it's Wisconsin I
understand your mom seems to be a mover
it sounds like it yeah she killed
herself so she moved on she shook I have
a little bit of Xanax out there no she
uh she was mentally ill okay so she was
like on a good path on a little bit of a
war path but she had borderline
personality disorder and then killed
herself three days before my wedding I'm
sorry oh my God no it's fine don't be
it's fine she'll give you a gift what's
the deal that was the gift oh man wow
building a subdivision not it's pretty
[ __ ] sweet yes you never made it what
happened is it like no so she the land
was left to us to my sister and I and
then we gave it back to my dad because
he lost it in the divorce so we're like
here take this back all right that's
pretty good my dad built a house on it
and he lives there now what about the
rest of the land oh here's the crazy
thing about that land we had a crazy
thing oh my gosh so this just in when my
dad got it um cop showed up at his house
and said that a guy that was on his
deathbed
um admitted to burying his wife there so
they had to like search the land for her
you know long time dead body or 1200
people you [ __ ] I know you guys are
really batting us
that's like a 90 murder rate yeah the
small towns are where it's at it is it
is it is wonky out there yeah you got
nothing else to do there's not a few
people yeah it's like drink and kill
people that's Wisconsin we had Gene we
had Dahmer it's like there's nothing to
do there's too much time alone you're
thinking too much yeah I imagine it was
beautiful though right it was a
beautiful scenery sounds like a [ __ ]
Cemetery what are you talking about
[ __ ] dead bodies all over the place
nice sunsets nice three months out of
the year and then it's snow and it's
great oh it got pretty bad huh aren't
you guys known for cheese sure how was
the cheese cheese and homicide
apparently I wasn't allowed to eat it my
mom was like had an eating disorder and
she wouldn't let us she like would pack
Slim Fast shakes in our lunch
yeah there's a lot of the listeners know
we're big really yeah she would put a
slim fast in a paper bag and then
because she didn't want me to is it Malt
Liquor what the [ __ ] are you hanging out
on the corner she didn't want it to look
like that so she would put a potato in
there to make it look like a full bag
okay it's like you know what would you
do with the potato nothing you're not
she didn't want me to get the carb she
just didn't want the bag to look empty
sweet
you're rolling into school every day
with a brown paper bag with the slim
Fest in there and uh uncooked potato yes
so you would just throw the potato out
yes you know how long it takes to cook a
potato it's not that long
throw it into the morning I'll be back
tomorrow yeah holy [ __ ] how many kids
were you in were in your school like in
your class 20 or 30. I don't remember
when I was in Catholic School it was
small it was like 15 but then when I
went to public school it was more okay
and how close was your school was it
closed or was it like a half hour it was
like no it was like two miles away for a
grade school it was like a mile away and
then my high school like the district
had to be a bunch of different small
towns obviously gotcha all right so the
high school was
eight miles away and how did you get to
high school boss car bus you took the
bus same thing with elementary school
bus yellow bus yes nice anybody ride
horses to school
no they took tractors really tractors
yeah but they leave them there while
they were in school yeah
like a car that's hillbilly yeah that's
what I'm [ __ ] talking about
um does anybody still live in the house
that you lived in understand what are
you talking about uh we had to sell it
after my mom died you sold it what was
the name of that street I actually do
wonder if those people know that
somebody died there I mean as they take
a look around the neighborhood I think
they can assume I think you have to tell
them right
not in Wisconsin you don't have to I
think they're telling somebody died in
there in California in certain States
you do okay
um what was the road that it was on to
the street Edgewood Avenue Ed that
doesn't sound like a farm
Edgewood Ave that sounds pretty nice it
does sound classy Avenues are a little
tough though I feel was it a a ranch
house no big house it was pretty big it
was a big house how many bedrooms we
talking
um five five bedroom house okay how many
baths
three at least I think four do you have
your own bathroom no my sister and I
shared one that's so pretty cool well
they're were they adjoining like she
came in from her room and you came here
from here of someone's house the Jack
and jills
is that the real term Jack and Jill
she's in real estate this probably
you're the first person to ever come in
here that had that kind of almost had
their own subdivision which is pretty
sweet no my sister did yeah but I mean
your family owns she is so it was only
you two yeah and what's the age
difference between you two a year and
nine months and do you speak to her
currently yeah okay you guys are close
no okay I mean we're not not close but
we were never close growing up and you
know she's she's a scientist she got her
PhD in cellular and molecular immunology
and pathology holy [ __ ] so she's trying
to cure glaucoma and I'm telling dick
jokes so we just have a very different
life yeah there you go yeah and is she
still in Wisconsin no she is at Duke
really she works at Duke yeah she's a
scientist yeah she was a good student
what about you were you a good student
uh yes because I had to be my mom was
very strict what are we talking SATs
what'd you pull in SATs I bombed because
I didn't I wasn't I have no idea I was
low like low percent I barely showed up
to the test I was so drunk GPA was wrong
I know I knew you're You're Sober now
yeah okay yeah let's take a walk back
there you're boozing when did you start
that 15. 15 you started posing you're
boozing pretty hard in high school oh
yeah like a bottle a night a bottle like
a bottle of parrot bay that was my thing
Parrot Bay yeah do they even still make
that I don't know when it's trashy it's
so bad man that's perfect
Malibu Big Jimmy Buffett fans how would
you score a bottle every day well it
wasn't every day whenever I partied my
friend had a fake ID yeah well that's
what you would get other kids would be
getting beers
just walk into a liquor store and buy
[ __ ] if you're confident enough yeah oh
yeah of course yeah yeah they play by
their own rules out there yeah it's
Wisconsin Hachi Machi damn all right did
you go to college yeah I went to
Marquette
that's a good school did you graduate
yes what'd you graduate with
a degree wise oh Communications and
psychology double major okay any sports
double Mage double Mage no but I did
what do you got the whole basketball
team
me too shout out to Temple University
are they D1 yeah oh that's good that
counts yeah it's like playing D3 we've
got some superstars in there for sure of
course so you're buying a division three
scrubs yeah at least you got some guys
with some potential I like it yeah
that's all right huh what was a family
vacation like growing up
well it depends so my dad I assume
eventful it was kind of like split my
dad and my mom had like very different
styles I would always go on fishing
trips with my dad and we still do that
and then my mom like tried to be fancy
so she would take us to like Paris or
Costa Rica or whatever but yeah we were
talking about that before you you like
Paris I love Paris now so they got
divorced when you were five so most of
your life they were they were split up
fighting mostly I mean because it's like
the eight-year divorce they took eight
years to get divorced and your mom kept
the house yeah and your dad moved out
into like an apartment into a spec house
where he was literally sleeping in the
closet okay exciting
very interesting did your dad rematch
was your dad were they either one of
them dating or get remarried at any
point yeah they both uh were dating my
dad remarried to my stepmom who was ex
stepmom thank God she was an alcoholic
Bridge Troll she was just like big she
looked like John Jovi with like big 80s
hair and [ __ ] I feel like every step
mom did yeah they all did she looked
like a dried orange peel and she we had
a tan he had to get a tanning bed for
her what yeah Annie bed in the house in
the spec house this guy's in the goddamn
closet she's got a Danny bed no this is
when we moved into a new house we were
renting and he he did work for trade and
he got her a tanning bed okay
[Music]
interesting ex-stepmom is a tough I have
one myself and just that level of
relationship to have do you still talk
to her at all oh no did they have kids
together oh no no kids my dad got his
tubes tied after what do you call it
tubes
vasectomy yeah
he got snipped how about the pet
situation growing up other than the
horses
um we had a German Shepherd at your
mom's at my mom's okay we also had a
husky that we had to put down because
there was a petting he was drinking yeah
there's a petting zoo up the street and
oh God it attacked a llama like swung
off of its jugular and killed the Llama
so we have to put that one down what did
the petting zoo make you do that yeah oh
my God they're gonna sue us and then um
we had cats also who lives near a
petting zoo that's wild I mean we've
done like 250 episodes and no one's like
yeah right next door to the bed the
crazy thing is we had a petting zoo near
my mom's house and then when my dad
finally got another house there was a
petting zoo across the street from there
too and there was like bears and tigers
and [ __ ] is that a big petting zoo area
is that a petting zoo destination
petting zoo isn't that where like most
of those tiger king-esque Farms off no I
think it's they're in the midwest he was
in the midwest right I thought he was in
the South yeah he was in Florida I
thought no no no he was not she was in
Florida he was in like
he was up there somewhere I don't think
you're right I believe I am so we're
gonna find that a second T-Bone hit him
hit me uh give me a second oh my God I'm
[ __ ] over here that would have been
perfect is he still alive or did he he's
in jail he's in the can he's hemmed up
right now yeah he was supposed to get
Pearl three Tiger King
um I haven't seen the thing so I don't
know what to search the Tiger King
location is no good why not
where does the Tiger King doesn't tell
me it's in the Bronx
he's eating a chopped cheese
Oklahoma okay I don't know where that is
that's not the South that's that's the
Midwest technology yeah that's the
Midwest there we go okay you're right
there you go all righty take that loser
shout out to Tiger King uh what was the
name of the supermarket you went to
Growing Up
Piggly Wiggly oh Piggly Wiggly huh did
you have a local pizza place
yeah Crossroads Crossroads Pizza they
throw out a decent pie
no not compared to literally anywhere
else in the world sure yeah I figured
the cheese would be good at least this
might be a stretch did you have a
Chinese spot out there yes and the name
of that was Chopsticks
it's like out of a board game ran by an
Irish couple yeah surprisingly great
yeah fast food yeah all right this is
pretty good yeah I go back and I'm like
I wonder if it holds up now that I've
eaten other it's great it's good all
right that ain't gonna catch it
Piggly Wiggly
and that was the lunch situation was
slim fast did your mom cook at all no
sometimes no she was pretty bad like she
one time she tried to make pork chops in
the slow cooker and she forgot about
them and then they just turned into like
hockey pucks and she still made us eat
them ah damn and if it wasn't a Slim
Fast you would sometimes do cheese
sandwiches it was just like American
cheese and bread
like Kraft singles or like sliced at the
deli no crap oh man those on a sandwich
those are meant to be melted by the way
they are the craft single they're the
best in eggs top shelf and eggs
um would you hit the deli counter at the
Piggly Wiggly would you guys get like
turkey and all that kind of stuff no I
can't stress enough that my mom had an
eating disorder and like so what were
you eating I mean Slim Fast what do you
mean that's it slim fast sometimes like
tuna casserole
if I went to a friend's house I would
steal their snacks because that's how
like I never wow so if they had like
Doritos I would steal them and then I
got caught and she's like you're
stealing my [ __ ] and I'm like I've never
had it it is awkward yeah no kidding I
live in Hell
Ranch in your hands so like let's say we
so you go into your your mom's Pantry
right or the whatever whatever you call
it you open it up where the food is
what's in there white wine okay I like
it slim fast I should have led with that
yeah
Merlot white wine Slim Fast maybe some
pretzels
that's about it Bare Bones okay did she
smoke no no you smoked yes and then you
quit yes at what age did you start
smoking so I started smoking when I was
at Marquette they were handing out Camel
crushes yeah as a promotion yeah the
camel person was a good person yeah I
mean I can't imagine that's still legal
I hot no there's no way yeah so I kept
saying no no no no I don't smoke and
then finally I was like oh my God if I
just take him will you leave me the [ __ ]
alone and I put them I had like maybe
three packs and I put them on my table
and then I made a new friend and she
came through and she was like oh my God
you smoke I smoke and I was like oh my
God yeah and we started smoking together
and then it was like the bitter winter
and we're outside smoking and she's like
do you want to know something crazy and
I was like sure she's like I didn't
start smoking until I saw that you
smoked and I was like that's how the
cats I'll joke
the camel always wins yeah yeah find
them at the petting zoo yeah then I
smoked for like seven years eight years
and then I quit I quit smoking
cigarettes and then I started vaping in
like January so I just went hypnot got
hypnotized to stop doing that and that
worked in January hypnotized I got
hypnotized like two weeks ago when you
were hypnotized were you unaware of
what's going on no you're you're aware
you can hear him could they tell you to
do stuff that you didn't want to do like
bang on your hand or talk about Macarena
or something yeah I mean I'm sure they
could but they don't now where was this
facility that you I picture LA right
above above like a pizza player above
something it was right next to
Chopsticks no it's in a guy's garage a
converted garage of course I just said
it was professional yeah it is well you
know everything it was hardly it's like
yeah it's the same guy that Ron White
went to to stop drinking it's like
people okay yeah right well then that
guy should be out not in his garage he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's got a wig on
he's got Hufflepuff pillows wait you got
hold on you got hypnotized by a guy in a
wake yes but I I knew he worked because
I got hypnotized from him like three
years ago to stop biting my name I can't
hypnotized by him he puts you under the
first time I ain't come back in six
months news again hey you're gonna start
smoking
you had to get hypnotized to go stop to
stop biting your fingernails yes how bad
was it so bad I used to like bite like
the skin like all the way down here yeah
yeah yeah
all right guys this guy costs by the way
275 a session cash only nope how many
sessions do you need to do it three okay
so it cost you about six beans yep all
right not bad not bad okay let's talk
about that butcher box love that butcher
backs miss your question you like
chicken do I like chicken cause let me
tell you something like top Quality Meat
you like wild caught you like grass-fed
grass finish no antibiotics Demi do you
like free range Kevin I love it yeah I
don't like being on a range I like free
range do yourself a favor do yourself a
favor get on that butcher box gang top
quality stuff yeah guys with talkers you
mainly raised no antibiotics no hormones
get what you want delivered right to
your doorstep free shipping the
continental US no surprise you throw it
in the freezer it lasts forever it's
fantastic they were like we've said
about a million times the good folks
over there put your box send us I I it
must have came on a with a forklift
there was so much chicken pork it was
unbelievable it was between I still I'm
still eating it it's fantastic I enjoy a
range of high quality cuts that are hard
to come by at the grocery store at an
amazing value exclusive member deals you
shave on big bucks on your favorite Cuts
uh recipe inspiration guides tips hacks
and some are even personalized so you
can cook up mouth-watering Meals love
that butcher box and listen
you might be thinking oh my God I'm
going I'm eating so many chicken breasts
they can't keep it in store at the
supermarket well listen to this take
chicken breast off your grocery list
from here on out because butcher boxes
offering our listeners incredible deal
that they've never offered before which
is saying a lot because the boys at
budget boxer Broncos free chicken for
you that's crazy eat that shove it up
your pee whole free chicken for a year
hit it you get two pounds of free-range
chicken organic chicken breast for free
in every order when you sign up at
butcherbox.com
ayg wow for the chicken alone you sign
up you save your money yeah crazy but
your box diet claim this deal at
butcherbox.com
let's talk about the boys that air
movement just a couple of guys with
their backs up against the wall a couple
of the college dropouts wanted to turn
the watch game upside down and let me
tell you something Bozo that's exactly
what they did with high quality watches
at discounted prices they now ship to
over 160 countries and they're in the
sunglass game they're in the the blue
blocker game it's top shelf stuff it's a
fantastic brand they pass the savings
right under you yeah guys it's fantastic
they sent us a bunch of gear oh yeah hi
Rock I just had my birthday didn't with
the team did you wear to watch I was out
there wearing what I was pointing point
over at the menu what's that over there
wait where's the check I do the chat
flashing the ice on it oh that watch
must have been thousands of dollars no
no no very affordable movement watches
have the look and quality of a 400 to
500 watch we pay at the department store
but at a fraction of the cost because
they were built online with their own
process from start to finish cut out the
middleman that's what we're doing
nowadays with these online companies
week we're cutting up the middleman
right now directly to you same thing
with movement if you want to elevate uh
your look with style that doesn't break
the bank then join movement and get 15
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mvmt.com garbage one
more time write it down mvmt.com garbage
do it do it what about uh the job
situation when you were growing up did
you work at all so my mom made me um
telemarket for her company yeah when I
was like 10. and I was like asking
people if they wanted to lower their
interest rates and I had no idea what
the [ __ ] I was talking about because I
was 10. wow they were like are you a
child
what was your quota a month yeah I only
ever made 100 because I was
uncommissioned only so so she had to
close she had to close the deal yeah
she's a Cutthroat business woman you
gotta keep costs down here's the great
part is she would make me do all this
work and then the money would go into my
college fund and then on my 18th
birthday she kicked me out of the house
and she stole my college so Jesus got
all of her money back where'd you go
when you get kicked out of the house my
dad's house just went over there yeah I
thought I was gonna go to ASU for school
because that's was the plan but then
when all my money was gone I had to ASU
Arizona State yeah okay Mary cat's
little great school man that's [ __ ]
yeah she was like a party school though
isn't that the one with like The Lazy
River yeah yeah I was trying to go there
and get herpes yeah
that's where like all the girls going
wild were shot yeah down in Arizona oh I
know what you're talking about
yeah what was the high school mascot
an Indian but we had to get rid of that
I think now it's the Bears okay but the
same thing happened at Marquette I don't
know what it was before but it recently
was the golden eagles when I got there
before that it was something else
something Native American related
probably gotcha gotcha gotcha what about
uh what was the Christmas situation do
you celebrate Christmas Christmas so
that's the thing Christmas was lit when
they had money and then it started
getting less and less lit you know it
was like it used to be all the [ __ ] and
then slowly I'm like oh they're losing
their money huh you guys did a tree yeah
real tree fake tree real tree real tree
colored lights white lights colored
lights colored lights what about in the
yard did you have a plastic Santa Claus
out there no any reindeer no we had a
big star like a big that's pretty close
is it blown up or like no it was my dad
made it out of wood and then lit it up
that's pretty good yeah okay that ain't
bad how big was the barn
big so 12 horses I mentioned yeah 14 or
15 stalls okay that ain't bad we had to
bale hay in the summer and that was
brutal out on Earth yeah how do you do
that well you get a tractor and then you
turn the hay you cut the grass turn it
into hay and then Bale it and you
literally have to pull it from the
um trailer up into the Loft to the hay
loft damn it's okay you were working
yeah it was [ __ ] hard I hated it
uh this is pretty specific Wisconsin but
did you ever go on a family trip to the
Mars Cheese Castle oh that's funny not a
family trip but like we go there for
cheese
just for cheese yeah it's not it's right
it's literally 20 minutes away from my
dad's house it's not made of cheese it's
a castle all they sell is cheese yeah
it's unbelievable yeah it's great it's
the best we should do that I like the
sound that happens yeah well it's kind
of in the middle of nowhere I don't know
where you guys would perform to get
there but because it's in Kenosha I
think
Kenosha what'd you guys do on
Thanksgiving where would you have it
really depended whose year it was if it
was my dad's year well God this is
tricky I don't even know
my mom's family would sometimes do
Thanksgiving and then if it was my dad's
I think we would just do it at my dad's
house okay because my dad had 12
brothers and sisters so his family stuff
was like massive but it was they were
all local everybody it was in the kind
of same vicinity yeah nice but you never
went out to eat for Thanksgiving mm-hmm
okay how old were you when you got your
passport
younger I guess if you were yeah
probably
okay that's classy
I assume you weren't allowed to eat in
your room as a kid that wasn't allowed
to eat I wasn't allowed to eat period
not cheap this is a wonky it's crazy man
it's crazy was there a fence around the
farm
there was a fence around the house oh
yeah well I guess we had an arena at the
bottom of the driveway too oh what for
the horses like where the horses run
around what was the fence made out of
around your house what not bad not bad
not chain link no
did you have butter in the house
my dad's house would you keep it on the
counter in the fridge counter really
that's right there we go fresh butter
just turned what about the ketchup was
the ketchup in the fridge or outside of
the the fridge okay could your dad cook
or will you get here okay so you're
getting at least solid meals when you
were there yes what was custody during
the week was it like weekly or every
couple of days and they stayed
relatively close to each other right
yeah Tuesday Thursday every other
weekend was my dad
oh it's fun and now you're running
you're out in Cali you're out in L.A a
house or an apartment house own it yes
you do okay now we're starting to move
in the right direction here you got a
garage yes you got a refrigerator in
that garage
yes you do what's in there honestly
non-alcoholic beers okay that's pretty
good how many car garage two nine can
you get two cars in there yes we have
the 63 Thunderbird in there and then the
Tesla
really
really a couple of bucks over here I
made money before I decided to stop
making money what did you make money how
did you make money I worked in
advertising for almost 10 years right
okay and made some Bank nice 401K yeah
really stock options yeah but that just
took a [ __ ] the stock market okay
now we're talking were you doing this
out in Los Angeles yeah really you were
in La advertising agent that's pretty
sweet you work on any big campaigns that
we would know yeah I used to work at
media arts lab which is Apple's camp but
agency
ever heard of it anything Apple's ever
done do you personally have credit for
any cool taglines like never had it
never will no anything like that no I
was I was recruiting I wasn't writing
okay you were recruiting other people to
come work at the yep okay make them
drink the Kool-Aid out there do you have
pets making them sign the ndas do you
have any pets out uh in L.A now yeah I
have a Min Pin named Biggie Smalls
what's a Min Pin miniature pincher
holy that sounds pretty classy and
here's this his name's Biggie Smalls
though
how's that not Min Pin sounds pretty
classy where do you shop now
for what for groceries groceries what's
your grocery store right now yeah Whole
Foods delivered
okay but mostly just fruit snacks it's
mostly just all the stuff I couldn't eat
as a kid
all right we got a little rags to riches
story going here I like this I like this
a lot you have a pool
growing up I did Growing Up you had a
pool above ground above ground above
ground pool on a 36 Acre Farms tough
look that you could probably use for
like a week yeah holy [ __ ] what about
now I think the pool was a nice marker
for like my mom's mental illness because
as she got sicker and sicker the pool
just turned into like a pot sure yeah
yeah I've seen that happen yeah above
ground pools they go they're like
avocados you catch they go bad real
quick yeah one Bad season it's a wrap
yeah just catch like a tree coming out
of the middle you're like what the [ __ ]
happened there no pool in L.A though
hmm anyone in your family pronounce the
days of the week as Monday Tuesday
Wednesday no anybody in your family say
banana well actually I don't know
there's a lot of people in my family I
don't know immediate family yeah okay
anybody say banana no okay does anyone
in your family own stock in the Green
Bay Packers and refer to themselves as
an owner that's hilarious no my body
does is that a thing yeah yeah they just
the weapon is a shareholder yeah package
is a publicly traded company yes it's
the only non-profit in the league holy
[ __ ] can own a piece of Aaron Rodgers
on the way out yeah he'd be more into
you guys than me but yeah do you have
any two dollar bills yes and I do really
yeah at the house no it's in my purse
not this one but really it has a good
luck charm yeah
okay hmm
anyone in your family have adult braces
no okay well not true yeah and my aunt
did
um bathroom
do you pee in the shower yes you do who
doesn't you brush your teeth in the
shower no do you have an electric
toothbrush or a regular toothbrush
electric uh body wash bars of soap body
wash body wash what are you rocking it
takes a certain kind of gal to use a bar
or something just get out of prison I
don't know man did you just hear the
first 10 minutes of this it's true she
could be using lava for all I know
something classy I think it's just like
tea tree or yeah I don't know okay tea
tree
and got a loofah in there yeah yeah she
does heated floors in the bathroom no
wow one shower head
yes straight up Rain no okay is there a
curtain or a door in the shower glass
door yeah is there a separate tub in the
shower
separate tub outside of the shower
okay
okay all right that's what I'm talking
about
um bedroom
how many pillows do you use to sleep
like four four behind your head what's
the positioning two behind my head and
one on each side of my body to hug me
like my mother never did wait a minute
hold on hold on are you are you are you
do you sleep on your back that's what
they do to infants so they don't roll
out of bed you sleep on your back yes oh
my God that's crazy and you put two
pillows next to you yeah and where do
your arms go like that
[ __ ] like [ __ ] Dracula Wild
I remember when my mom used to sleep
like that and I was like she's a [ __ ]
psycho and now I sleep like that it's
betterhelp.com folks yeah TV in your
room growing up or now now both yes you
have a TV no I wasn't allowed to watch
TV growing up no TV and that was there a
TV in the fat like in the living room
yes okay there was no cable it wasn't
attached to anything like everyone
you could watch like this everything's
cool here
that's so crazy
throw everybody out the scent yeah do
you eat in your room now yes you do okay
not often but I'll eat pizza in bed
every once in a while Pizza in bed
that's pretty good that's pretty good
what's your pizza spot in La that you
get delivered Abbott's Pizza on Abbot
Kinney it's so good okay and what's your
Chinese spot out in L.A I don't really
have one okay that's pretty classy
attention is kind of all right but
fancy I don't think you can say that but
okay
uh anyone in your family ever worked at
Hooters
no anybody in your family ever been on
the show Cheaters no everywhere kiss me
on my Irish t-shirt
I might have in college the partying
days have you any member of your family
ever claimed to have seen a UFO
okay so my my sister and my dad have
legitimately claimed okay so we do this
trip every year up north in Canada where
we're out in the middle of nowhere we
basically like we hike like five miles
we get in a canoe we canoe so you have a
good relationship with your dad yeah my
dad's the best awesome we canoe we're in
the middle of nowhere no running water
no electricity nothing and we go fishing
you literally just eat the fish you
catch whatever anyway he can do all that
stuff yeah he's a man's man yeah yeah
that's all yeah and you can you do that
stuff can you got a fish yeah you can
yeah that's pretty cool yeah so my dad
my sister and my sister's husband were
fishing and they all swear on their
lives it's like broad daylight okay that
hold on where are they where they're
exactly in the middle of it's called Mac
lake in Canada okay broad daylight where
are you I was back on yeah
I was back on the island just reading or
something at the at the little campsite
yeah yeah so they take the canoe out to
they take the canoe out and they all
said that this giant like light orb was
on top of the lake and it was huge and
then they all looked at it we're like do
you see this do you see this and they're
like yes what the [ __ ] is it and then it
zipped across the lake and it went up
and there's no drinking there's no drugs
there's no nothing on this trip and it's
three people there from a cell phone or
something there's no cell phones there's
nothing you're in the middle of nowhere
with no running water no electricity
that's a legitimate [ __ ] UFO site
yeah absolutely the first one I've
gotten I've been asking that question
for like three months yeah that's
[ __ ] they all came back and they were
just like oh he just saw UFO and I'm
like no you didn't and they're like no
we did and I was just saying what do you
believe them what's your thought I
believe that they're not crazy yeah I
believe they're not crazy and it's all
wrong and it was the other side it was
big it couldn't have been like balls
huge it was huge and they all saw it and
they all like looked at each other and
were like do you see this yeah they all
saw freaking me out yeah that's what I
like death and UFOs that's what this
this thing's titled if we if we went to
your house uh shoes off when we walk in
no shoes on yeah okay whatever you want
what kind of water if I ask for a water
what are you offering me there sparkling
water or filtered or what do you have
what do you mean exactly we have a Brita
no we have a system like a wired system
through the whole house yeah wait the
system not the thing you screw onto the
faucet no no no like it was put in by a
plumber really yeah a filtration system
so you just now does that come out of
the regular sink in the kitchen right
next to it
she's pretty classic what's your credit
score looking like 8 20. well holy [ __ ]
what kind of credit cards you got got an
Amex uh no I have the chance
a 20. have you ever met anybody that
made 20 credit score I don't think I had
I think I don't think the president has
an H1 no can I wash your car or
something like that
um
Chase Sapphire Reserve is the best
credit card look at you chase Sapphire
Reserve they have their own line at the
bank you go you go over to the side
don't you yeah you're there casually
I only have one former ID can I show
caches
Chase that's good man it's breathing the
reserve is nice yeah next man myself do
you have an Amex Amex is I I don't but I
feel like a lot of places don't take
AMEX that's the one problem or has that
been resolved I think I if if they don't
if somebody has not accepted card it's
gonna be Amex I haven't ran into anybody
that hasn't taken it um I also have only
had it for like two my drug dealer
doesn't like I'm saying that right now
it's a little thing okay let's talk
about liquid IV liquid I visual let me
tell the good people out there one of
the worst things you can do for your
body with the exception of looking like
me is be dehydrated liquid IV get you
done get you hydrated two times faster
than regular water when you put one
stick in a 16 ounce bottle of water it's
absolutely fantastic it hydrates you and
here's the turkey what's that it's
absolutely delicious I'm a pina colada
man myself but I wouldn't kick the green
apple out of bed I can tell you that
sure it's fantastic
uh I use it for when I'm insanely
hungover and it's fantastic that also
works I took it down out of the shore
we're down there and why what a whole
family down there booze and begging butt
whole thing after another Telly Nutters
and Sam Pizza everybody wakes up hits uh
hits the liquid IV on a beach boogie
board and body surfing backflips we'll
get you right back you know why because
they got the essential vitamins they got
uh the B3 the B5 the V6 to B12 vitamin C
contains three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drink they got you
covered grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 15
off when you go to liquid iv.com use our
promo code garbage support the show at
checkout that's 15 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code garbage liquid
iv.com throw it
back
anyone in your family ever represented
themselves in court my mom really she
till the day she died she did The
Divorce by herself the divorce she did
The Divorce by herself she did
everything she was tied up in litigation
for her whole life she'd love to sue
people that was her hobby she sued
people to stay alive after the bubble
burst and the market went crazy for real
estate that was the end of real estate
for her and then she just sued people
for the rest of her life and then the
reason I mean did she win any of the
cases not really so when she killed
herself it was because she was doing
Court to like basically give the house
that she lived in over because it was
like she had pushed it and pushed it and
tried to Sue and Sue and they were like
no you owe us give the house over to who
the banker the bank yeah okay so she
owed more on it than it was worth and so
she was supposed to be in court that day
and then she just decided to go like a g
damn Hachi munchie you guys big on
people growing up huh were you big gun
people growing up my dad was he could
shoot my dad has North of 60 guns 60
guns the [ __ ] goes down I know where I'm
going yeah the [ __ ] big guy's house
when was the last time when you were
when was the last time you were on a
boat and where was it
I was just on a boat where was I oh
Miami
okay for boat week is that a thing yacht
week is it called right that's what all
the rich people do I was out there for
Rolling loud and I just wound up on a
yacht a yacht very nice that's what
we're talking about have you or anybody
in your family ever had a Discover card
I don't know about what my family's up
to but I haven't had one no hmm can you
speak any of the languages no you fly
first class sometimes
what decides that where I'm going how
long the flight is like if I'm going to
Europe it will I'll go first but if not
now you mentioned that you said you've
been to Paris seven times where else
have you been
and is this how much was in your
childhood with your mother and how much
is in your was in your is in your adult
life so I only went to Paris with my mom
once okay and then the rest of it's been
in my adult life okay so Paris Prague
Munich
um
Poland Krakow and Poland where else have
we got oh the UK obviously isn't it
Annette
um it's pretty well traveled you got
married special from Hoda housewife
you're going through a divorce now
though yeah where did you guys get
married in Nicaragua on a private island
really what's he doing yeah he works in
advertising he's a creative director
well cash yeah does well yeah all right
hmm Private Island married how many
people are at the wedding 17. really
what'd you pull in from the wedding or
when you're that well nothing it was no
gifts it was no gifts it was just come
and party we just all partied and popped
Molly and you know all right Molly yeah
it was like your grandparents and [ __ ]
there no no they weren't invited
um
[ __ ] our faces off
wait that's how you got married yeah it
was his parents and then my dad and my
Wicked stepmomster and then my sister
and her dad do Molly no did his parents
do Molly no you were doing that no but
nobody did Molly except for me and my
friends okay and then we somehow flagged
down cocaine someone got a hold of
someone like in the middle oh yeah South
America must have been tough a South
America wedding how did you find it on
an island in the middle of Lake
Nicaragua it's falling out of the trees
he gave it to your customers yeah
all right that's pretty good A no gift
wedding that might be the classiest
thing
if you're already spending that much
money to come every so you don't want to
like also be like give up who did you
did you pay for anybody to get down
there like your parents or his parents
are like that no okay
huh now if you were gonna go to a
wedding Friend's Wedding
it's you and uh you know close friend
close friend what are you giving in the
envelope
right now
maybe just give them advice be like hey
don't do it oh it's true yeah I guess
you are a little spiteful in the moment
of like you know what I don't [ __ ]
know she forgot to mention the hundred
dollar bills ripped in half so you can
split it up into the divorce yeah it
says Love Is A Lie
holy [ __ ] have you ever smoked a black
in mind how much money would you give
uh I give 200 ahead if it's me and my
wife's talking 400. somebody close five
damn yeah what do you mean I don't have
it like that he gave me a Target gift
card by the way so I wasn't invited to
the wedding now but I did take Molly
that's that possible it's a long story
that day
it's a long story
um we got a very small just family
and then covet hit we were supposed to
we did a city hall thing and then we
were supposed to have a big party and
then covet hit so plus he despises me
right that's true rightly so
um we have a checkered past let's talk
about uh the kitchen at your place now
so you said that you know growing up the
Slim Fast your mom didn't cook you take
care of the kitchen now you like having
a lot of stuff in there yeah yeah uh
what do you what do you what's the
mayonnaise situation
Dukes
okay you're all right you know that
you're all right that's basically
helmets Yeah
Mississippi I think they changed it over
there way better all right it's the same
thing I think you think I think it's the
same I think the same people make just
like a different marketing you should
know that you're an advertising yeah no
kidding um not anymore you have any cool
um small kitchen appliances the juicer
the juicer air fryer what brand of
juicer are we cooking I think it's a
Nutribullet okay KitchenAid you got any
KitchenAid stuff
yeah the big blender thing yeah that's
nice that's expensive what's the uh
what's like the fridge and the range
stainless biking sub Z what are you
rocking
it's Fisher and paycal is that that
sounds expensive yeah did you build it
did you guys build this house Fisher and
paykill I got that coming up and I uh
Dukes and Hellman's are completely
different okay Duke's contains a
combination of distilled and cider
vinegar while Hellman's only contained
distilled vinegar which can which makes
Duke's Tangier Hellman's also contains
lemon juice concentrating sugar Dukes is
the only mass-produced mayonnaise that
does not include sugar Dukes is better
look at you [ __ ] delicious look at
you I can't get a read on this goddamn
bro
she's got like Boutique high-end ranges
but she's giving 100 bucks at a wedding
I don't know did you always get in
cuckoo did you always kind of have
high-end I want to keep my money you
know it's true Did you always kind of
have high-end taste growing up
I don't even think I had the option but
I mean even though you couldn't you
couldn't make it happen did you oh yeah
you always wanted that yeah yeah gotcha
and my mom always did too she would like
drive us around to like the really nice
neighborhoods and be like one day I'm
gonna live here that never happened but
gotcha your sounds like you're doing it
did you guys build this house no you
just bought did you remodel when you
moved in it was all in there hmm
I'll be moving out but I only got two
weeks left living in an apartment yeah
we got you in just a great time yeah
[ __ ] case closed yeah I'm gonna take
your fish kill you guys are selling the
house or is he staying there he's gonna
keep it he's gonna keep it yeah buying
you out I hope yeah nice all right make
a couple of bucks yeah
pretty pretty you ever date a guy who
sold weed yeah oh man that's a tough
look why that was like he was like the
high school football hero and then also
a drug dealer that's a little different
that's stereo that's not on that's not
on brand with the high school football
hero to be also moving weight out of the
back of the [ __ ] yeah he moved weight
all through college and then now he
sells Windows there you go
in dime bags yeah little tiny ones
um did you have any social accolades
like that in high school prom queen
anything like that I know everyone hated
me okay why I was largely hated I think
because I wanted so badly to be liked
that it was just much easier to hate did
you play any sports played volleyball
played volleyball okay you didn't play
volleyball at Marquette did you no okay
that wasn't that good that's okay that's
okay hmm was the last time you had
lasagna
oh geez I don't know
a while ago how about meatloaf a year
ago uh meatloaf recently my dad I was
just home recently and my dad had some
meatloaf that was pretty much puts out a
nice meatloaf yeah he puts the he puts
like ranch seasoning like just the
powder in the meat yeah and it's [ __ ]
it's trashy but I respect it that's real
trash
it's like the powder
I know what you're talking about that's
putting the Hidden Valley Ranch powder
yeah it doesn't belong in an Italian
it's the pure enough
in Italian yeah I thought we said
lasagna no yeah
if that was the case oh man that just
bothered me I'm like
as I read the cans on this [ __ ] show
any ice cream in your freezer uh salt
and straw what's that
she names cool [ __ ] dude salt and straw
is the best it's from Portland it just
recently came to La the cookie dough
salt and straw is probably the best
where do you have to get that at Whole
Foods no that's Alton straw it's it's
ridiculous it's almost a joke how much
it costs I think it's like 15 wait hold
on a second hold on a second hold on a
second the do they sell it in the
grocery store you have to go to the
place well Postmates
okay but it's in pints yeah and it's
like 15 a pint holy Shack on the
Postmates right it's usually like eighty
dollars for ice cream
huh that's [ __ ] Wild
do you have any frozen pizzas in the
freezer yes what brand what are you
rocking Holly power yeah what's your uh
boys I'm a big cauli Power Man myself
what's your poison I like the all veggie
that's where you lose me it's pretty
pepperoni man myself
that's pretty good I honestly didn't
even know they made pepperoni because I
buy everything online so I haven't even
right right cauliflower is all right uh
do you travel with a neck pillow yes
what color red is it old no
but it's red I didn't want red take your
shoes off on the plane yes will you
bring food on them girls
what kind of food do you bringing on a
plane granola bars fruit snacks that's
fine you're not like getting a burger at
like Shake Shack and taking it no I
learned my lesson one time I was leaving
Chicago and I got a Chicago dog
I would say meet me at the bulkhead
we're going after it and I was eating it
in the seat next to me and the guy
looked at me and he was like dead in the
eyes and he's like you're an animal
that's [ __ ] nuts I was like I'm
hungry a Chicago dog so there I am I got
three bratwurst on me that's crazy holy
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] great do you have a
regular pepper shaker do you have the
grinder grinder Himalayan salt or
regular Himalayan yeah though
yeah you though do you use the bathtub
do you take baths yes you do you set it
up nice to candles the whole nine yards
that's pretty cool mom what are you
doing bath bomb Epsom salt shout out to
the bath bomb are you doing a flavor
that's some salt are you doing yeah
straight up straight up okay all right I
like a nice flavor buddy I don't think
it's called flavor you're not eating it
you're not supposed to eat it I tried
one of them no wonder why I'm dehydrated
in like the tens that wasn't the same
thing though they weren't snorting that
stuff were they I don't know no no no
that was just that was the street name
for the drug I think that was the drug
it was some sort of comp like chemical
compound that they get under the guise
of it's a bath salt like so they can
sell it right so you should go to like
it was very short-lived it was like I
eat that guy's face do you guys remember
Salvia did you ever smoke Salvia no oh
man I watched a guy jump not watch if I
watched a video of a guy jump out the
front window the window and this girl
take a hit off of it and he jumps out
the picture rolls up the side of the hat
like side of the wall like he's talking
Spider-Man then out the way it was did
he die no he hopped up and came back and
there's another hit music
yeah get back up Daddy-o yeah I remember
I smoked 40 xlvia out of a bong once and
I just sat there on my couch and it felt
like a bowling ball was hitting me in
the head for like I thought it was four
years like the trip felt like it was
four years long and then I got out and I
was like how long was that and my friend
was like nine seconds five minutes yeah
and we have plans for the rest of the
night and I was like No And I just went
to bed and I slept for like 16 hours I
was like how is this [ __ ] legal when did
you get sober uh I quit drinking right
after my mom's funeral so December 11
2017. okay
but I have dabbled with other stuff like
I quit drinking and then I was like you
know still popping Molly and doing coke
for a while and then I got to a wedding
yeah and then I got fully sober for
three years and then I relapsed on weed
last year and now I'm fully sober again
so great good good job of course yeah
ever been arrested yeah
what do you got uh DUI Arizona I went to
jail for 30 days
in the can no I went to Beverly Hills
pay to stay
um wait a minute hold on a second you
got picked up in Arizona yeah so I had
to lawyer up because I was working in
advertising at the time
like that she said that like she's in
the mob though I had a lawyer up call up
30. she's all right I'll tell you that I
can't get a [ __ ] read on her I want
to call her the biggest piece of trash I
ever talked to and then she's doing pay
to play white collar crimes I don't know
what's happening I'm not 100 sure if
you're classy or Garbage but you're cool
as [ __ ] I can tell you that
um yeah no because I it was Tent City in
Arizona at the time and that was when I
forget the name of the sheriff but he
was having a Joe Sheriff Joe yes famous
guy in the tennis yeah yeah and he was
having women and like chain gangs and
[ __ ] and guys old school I think he's
dead now I think well if he's not dead
he's fired he's not working there
anymore yeah but my lawyer was like
you're gonna kill yourself if you go
here so she ended up negotiating
shooting a deal where I could do the
Beverly Hills pay to stay but it's
embarrassing because I did have to have
my employer sign off on it like I was
like I'm gonna be in jail for the next
30 days if you could just sign that in
Beverly Hills though yeah it was like
literally right off Rodeo Drive it was
ridiculous was it nice it's jailed but
yeah it's probably the nicest jail you
could it's like the same [ __ ] that
Epstein got on his first offense
you had to pay to go there yeah you paid
like I think it was 150 a night and then
you could leave Monday through Saturday
eight to eight to go to work that's not
bad
that's not bad yeah it's not jail yeah
that's a good that's better than the
apartment I live in
that's crazy it's jail The First 48 were
solitary I had to sit down and think
about my life you're drinking toilet
bellinis yeah
[Applause]
I was leaving work early to get drunk
and drive myself back to jail drunk
he had a car in jail I wasn't supposed
to they were just idiots
I was like I'm in for a DUI and I was
having them validate my parking
like you guys are if you guys are this
stupid I'm gonna keep breaking the law
what do you keep your butter
uh on the counter you do really what
kind of butter are you buying no no just
it's probably awesome I don't know just
salted do you own any turquoise jewelry
no
no
okay
hmm what was your first concert Elton
John okay how old were you
12 maybe who'd you go with my mom and my
aunt all right that's pretty good yeah
was it I really wanted to go to like the
Backstreet Boys or Britney Spears and my
mom's like one day you'll thank me
is she right yes no John's pretty
awesome Elton John's pretty sick um well
you buy stuff at a duty-free shop no
okay I'm not against it when I used to
drink I used to like when I went some
cigarettes yeah do you have any magnets
on your fridge
no is there a calendar in your kitchen
no
you have a landline no you have checks
you have a checkbook yes you do yes do
you use the checks yes at the grocery
store no you can't or what what do you
use your checks for
[Laughter]
you already got the new place yeah uh in
L.A Beverly Hills yeah how many bedrooms
just one okay imagine it's nice though
pretty nice you can see the jail from
from
I'm just back girls I'm back
all righty
have you ever done any jewelry with your
name on it probably when I was younger
back when you were yeah you know when
they used to put like your name on a
grain of rice or something big on the
[ __ ] Boardwalk yeah name on a grain
of rice yeah I got one all right this
has been a very hot button issue okay
lately
okay say more than one person maybe you
and your husband when you guys were
together
um you're making dinner all right you're
both home you're both off you're making
dinner you're gonna have some spaghetti
is that in the realm of possibilities
that you guys would maybe make spaghetti
together
do you use one box of pasta to one jar
of sauce using
the making the whole pasta and using the
whole jar
no that's too much I think thank you I
think I think thank you the trick about
noodles usually you thought she was
gonna side with you on carb intake
that's wild well the the trick about
pasta is you like never think it's
enough and then you make it and it's way
too much and then you just put it in the
fridge and then have it later
sure so you're taking the so you're
taking no like half the Rocks you're
wrong and then put you put the half a
box of open spaghetti back in the
cabinet that's gonna run away no it's
not that's crazy it's not crazy we also
have like a container where you just put
it in there that's classy where it's on
display we don't know how many boxes it
is that's pretty what else do you have
in those kind of things
so I could tell myself it's half a box
we need five boxes
um and there's no rules that's plausible
deniability that's like breaking the
Matrix
uh what else do you have in those those
cylinders quinoa
canola I don't know what that is quinoa
is good you have quinoa you have flour
out like that no
you do coffee wait no I usually don't
drink caffeine I'm caffeine up today and
I won't sleep for three days herbal tea
yes
you have a go-to brand
flower child
man
she's high-end she is but also do you
even know what flower child is no but it
sounds
it's not uh Golds or whatever the Lipton
hey I'm a Lipton man shout out to them
um will you take snacks into a movie
theater or you buy them there
I mean I haven't been to a movie theater
theater okay what's the most expensive
piece of clothing that you own
yeah go ahead
you can tell us clothing or jewelry you
tell me
um I have a Rolex and then
I have like a five thousand dollar
jacket
what's the Jack was that was that Marc
Jacobs or something like that
TJ Maxx
people who think they're famous they're
fancy yeah where'd you get that pennies
like a Coach bag what do you got Steve
Madden that's how she just laughed at
you dropping what you thought was the
coolest designer you could pull she
laughed in your face
you can tell he shops at Marshalls oh
he's a big Marshall's guy yeah I used to
about 100 pounds ago
the Rolex
what's that what's that kicking datejust
yeah probably like 15 to 17. where'd you
get that as a gift nice
nice hmm okay if you order uh takeout
right or delivery or whatever uh you get
back to the house well you plate it or
will you eat out of the container it
comes in container
it does but usually a container well you
eat over the sink at your house no
uh-huh I'll eat over the trash
interesting that's no good why that's no
good it's like a burrito or something
you'll stand you get a whole burrito and
I imagine your trash can is pretty fancy
they used to do you step on it and it
opens up yeah so you'll stay fancy the
bar is real low on this show I don't
know if you picked up is it a trash can
that has the uh trash can and the
recyclables in the same thing yeah those
are nice and so you just you'll you'll
still must be doing well you'll step on
it open it up and stand there need a
burrito and eat a whole burrito I mean
yeah when it starts falling apart that's
when I really you put hot sauce on the
burrito yeah
do we watch TV when you eat when you
take like you'll sit in the living room
do you have TV trays
yes flat screen TV yes central air
conditioning yes
this is history she's got a flat screen
TV she's got one of those jars for pasta
that sit on the counter of course she
does growing up did you have milk with
dinner yes oh do you still do that no
no my dad does though he drinks milk out
of the gallon still probably get good
milk out in Wisconsin yeah cows are so
close uh being from Wisconsin how do you
feel about the cheese curd
the best thing ever
yeah
have you ever had Culver's
I don't think so oh God next time you
guys are in the there's definitely some
[ __ ] bar if I remember okay well
then they probably weren't good ones you
need to have good ones did they squeak
in your teeth
I don't think I would that would sell me
on it being good to be honest with you I
think that would go in the conscious
yeah do they scream when you bite them
those are the good ones
what was the last dinner you made you
cooked are you cooking
my husband cooked a lot okay now I'm
eating I'm about to eating yeah I'm
eating like an yeah yeah so are you both
in the house right now or he's no I'm
out you're out I'm out okay
okay yeah the last thing I cooked I
think was like Trader Joe's Pasta shout
out to them love Trader Joe's do you
have air freshener in your car no
hmm
so you're at you're let your sink
bathroom sink or kitchen sink either or
you have the thing as hand soap do you
also have a thing of hand lotion no you
have hand towels in your bathroom yes
what kind of hand soap you're doing
uh Aesop
I don't know what that is I know do all
your towels match
yeah do you put the eight do you put the
hand lotion you buy into a different
container and then throw out the plastic
one that's pretty good what are the what
are your towel brand Martha Stewart what
do you use honestly Costco Costco
Kirkland Kirkland they're the nicest
towels go get one and then tell me it's
crazy they're the best shout out to
Kirkland Kirkland brand is hmm you do uh
you do laundry okay put in the washer in
the dryer will you leave their clothes
in the dryer and get dressed in front of
the dryer or will you take it and fold
it and put them back in the in your
drawer
my cleaning lady does the laundry
okay I've heard everything I need to
hear
okay favorite flavor of ice cream
cookie dough we talked about that okay
cookie cookie dough would be
just follow-up questions
well you said that that place makes good
cookie doesn't actually mean it was your
favorite ice cream place come on
favorite place you brought here get your
head out of your ass you're making us
look bad favorite favorite flavor of
Gatorade
I don't even know the flavors but red
fruit punch yeah oh allow it I like it
the floss every day yes every day yes
twice a day once okay in the morning
sorry at night or in the morning
okay when was the last time you had
Lobster
I don't really like lobster but the last
time I had it was in February okay
do you like seafood yes
crab is my favorite but I don't know
crab man too I don't know [ __ ]
expensive yeah
I love crab 110 for a crab leg now
you get one crab leg then they punch you
in the throat it's like what the [ __ ] is
happening it's crazy do you steal from
the airport no I don't steal it I used
to steal from everywhere now I don't no
she served a nickel this broad yeah no
it's wild
um I mean I just have one more question
when was the last time you had fast food
In and Out Burger doesn't count
uh last week at McDonald's you did okay
is that your favorite Mickey D's
probably and what well Taco Bell's up
there okay that's respectable what do
you what's your go-to over there Mickey
D's
it's yeah go ahead
asparagus a fish fillet sandwich with
extra tartar sauce
I don't care where you worked if you
knew these jobs you went to jail you
give a hundred bucks at a wedding and
you like fish fillet you wrap it the
[ __ ] up yeah you're garbage kid and I
love it shout out to the fish a very
wonky that's a meal that's the meal
you're going for you're getting the fish
fillet meal with extra tartar sauce oh
that's cradle he's put a gallon on it I
wonder you're a dukes man yeah it needs
the tank
she needs the action get you in the
jugular wow thank you so much for coming
Brittany Schmidt 100 garbage buddy guys
check out the special anything else you
want to plug social media shows anything
bad my social media is Brittany Schmidt
just at Brittany Schmidt awesome yeah
super funny such a fantastic story we
love you thank you so much for coming in
thank you thank you what do you got for
him guys roll over the road check out
those live shows the tickets are going
yeah come see us get them we appreciate
the sport love you we love you we'll see
you next week peace
[Music]